[موسيقى]
معاذ اسس ووضع نظاما سياسيا كل من جاءوا
بعده من الدول والممالك في العالم
الاسلامي كلها استمرت عليه الدوله الامويه
وضعت نظما ودواوين من جاءوا بعدهم له
يعودون اليهم فقط وسعوا ويعودون الى هذا
الاساس عفوا هذا النظام الذي وضعه معايا
بن ابي سفيان هو انه حينما حدثت احداث
الفتنه والاضطرابات كان لابد من وضع نظام
سياسي وتاسيس نظام سياسي ينقذ العالم
الاسلامي من الاضطراب والتفكك فاسس معاويه
ابن ابي سفيان اول عائله ملكيه وراثيه
تحكم في تاريخ الاسلام هناك ناس غضبوا
كثيرا من هذا النظام وانه تغيير في نظام
حكم الخلافه على الراشده جميل من حقك ان
تختلف مع اي نظام سياسي ولكن كل الدول
العباسيه بعد الدول والممالك
وراثيه وتسمي نفسها ايضا بنفس الاسم
هذه الاحكام المعلومات التي تحدث عن دور
معاويه في تاسيس هذه النظم والدواوين هي
ما توافر عليه كثير من المؤرخين في
المصادر الاصيله والمصادر الكلاسيكيه في
التاريخ الاسلامي نتحدث عن الطبري ابن
كثير وابن كثير والبلاذري والمسعودي وكثير
ممن كتبوا عن سيره وتاريخ الدوله الامويه
حتى من مناويي الدوله الامويه هم يؤكدون
على دور معاويه بن وسفيان في تاسيس مثل
هذه الامور ومن اشهر هذه المؤلفات هناك
نمط في التاليف كتب الاوائل والتي تحدث عن
اول من فعل كذا اول من فعل كذا من ابرزها
مثلا كتاب الاوائل لا بهلال العسكري وفيه
فصل الاوائل في الملك وفي هذا الفصل ياتي
معاويه بن ابي سفيان رضي الله عنه اول ملك
في الاسلام اول من وضع نظام ديوان البريد
اول من وضع ديوان الختم وهكذا هذه كلها
معلومات
متوافره وتوافر واكدها كثير من المؤرخين
والباح ثين في مصادر التاريخ الاسلامي
الاصيله
[موسيقى]